welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and with Thanos possibly returning
to the MCU will we finally see the
destruction of xandar that preceded the
events of infinity War potentially gave
us the origin of Nova and finally get to
the bottom of how exactly Thanos was
able to do it and a galacti sized reason
why Josh broland tells comicbook.com
that he is hearing through the grapevine
that Thanos is coming back Beyond his
vocal cameos in the alternate universes
of what if what do those shows really
tell us about the history and the
infrastructure of xandar that makes
thanos's off-screen destruction of
xandar so interesting and will his
return be something as obvious as a
multiversal cameo in secret Wars as like
a punching bag to show how deadly God
Emperor Doom can be or are we going to
learn a secret about Thanos that he is
actually on the right side of cosmic
history hey new rock stars is doing a
live show on Thursday February 15th in
Los Angeles at brain dead Studios we're
going to talk about the big news that
comes out of Super Bowl weekend we're
going to do stuff that we never get to
do on YouTube tickets are still
available through the link in the
description come hang out with us okay
in recent days while out promoting Dune
part two Josh broland chatted with
com.com about the fact that Thanos was
apparently the most killed Marvel
villain I suppose they're referring to
his two deaths in ingame and a few
deaths that we saw in the what if series
counting zombie Thanos and Josh broland
said that he heard kind of like through
the Great Vine that they are going to
bring him back and burlin went on to
clarify that the animated version of
Thanos in the what if series is its own
thing he's referring to the liveaction
version of Thanos and unlike the Dead
version of Thanos that they brought back
as like a digital asset this would be
one that Josh Berlin had to suit up
again to play now because it was
comicbook.com with the scoop here we got
to shout out our man Brandon Davis and
explore the possibility that this is
something we could see with Nova in a
movie or show Brandon I know how much
you love Nova so Nova Richard Ryder was
a Teran recruited by Roman day of xandar
John C Riley's character and Guardians
of the Galaxy Roman day finds Richard
upon the decimation of the Nova court
and he chooses him to carry on the
banner of the elite Nova cor Squad
giving him the power of the Nova force
and the xandarian worldmind that would
speak through to him currently in the MC
you the planet of xandar is in Ruins
because Thanos attacked it in the events
leading up to Infinity War to acquire
the Power Stone but we never saw that
sequence we have not seen xandar since
and it's something that Marvel fans have
been dying to see we know the sequence
was at least scripted out according to
the infinity War screenwriters Marcus
and mcely who said on the commentary for
the film that a version of the movie
opened with the destruction of xandar
they said we wrote a version of Thanos
attacking xandar and it had a similar
purpose in the script to what nowhere
does now it was a place where Thanos and
gomorah encountered each other but the
fact of the matter is is you know
exactly what if Thanos went to Xander to
get that stone you know what happened it
was a big battle and he got it but while
discussing Infinity war with
comicbook.com in October 2019 Marcus and
mcy went into further detail about what
this was going to be and they said quote
we actually had I remember in the big
Manifesto thing that we did where the
first work we did on these movies every
possible storyline that you could take
from what's around that Nova has the
xandarian worldmind yeah the xandarian
worldmind was that after it was almost
going in this conception he would be The
Herald not unlike the Hulk who is
actually standing in for the Silver
Surfer but that one member of the Nova
course survived thanos's attack the
xandarian world M would be the voice of
Glen Close because you had her and why
not and he would be the Richard ryer and
he would come to Earth so just to repeat
instead of the Hulk crash landing on
Earth proclaiming Thanos is coming
something that the infinity War writers
took from Silver Surfer and The Infinity
Gauntlet storyline he was supposed to be
the one who crash lands to Earth in
their original conception for the
infinity War film it would have been
Richard Ryder Nova escaping from a
destroyed zand and that the xandarian
world mine would have been the voice of
Glen Close Irani ryel Nova Prime in
April 2023 Jim Starin who created the
Thanos character in the Marvel Comics
told the near mint Edition channel that
this Thanos xandar scene would have been
45 minutes long and that they actually
shot it according to him but about a
month before the movie came out I got an
email or something from Joe saying the
45 minutes of Thanos that we had at the
beginning of the infinity War we had a
cut there was a whole sequence of him
getting the first Gem and they had to
cut that out uh they had shot it but
they never wanted to spend the money on
the effects and that and they didn't
want the movie to be as long as the
second one was they didn't realize it
was going to be quite the hit it was now
if there were 45 minutes of footage that
the rooster Brothers actually shot with
the actors and then edit it together
folks we would have seen something from
it in the six years since Avengers
Infinity War like set photos of the
actors in moap suits or at least
references to this huge production by
anyone else who worked on the movie or
at least like concept art of ruin xandar
because we saw concept art of like every
other permutation of stuff that wasn't
even in the movie we would have seen
some previs animation something it's
just we've seen all other pieces of this
movie including That Awkward previous
footage of the removed early smart Hulk
sequence in Infinity war that they
removed from the film so a 45-minute
sequence of a planet being destroyed
would have added tens of millions of
dollars to the production budget and it
just would have been way bigger deal if
something like that got shot and then
got removed like people would have lost
their jobs I think Jim Starin might have
either misspoke or maybe they did like
storyboard this out or drawn up some
concept art or maybe even some previous
animation that looked really goofy but
they decided not to shoot it because it
would have had to have been 45 minutes
now a year ago The Hollywood Reporter
claimed that a previously announced Nova
series for Marvel Studios was still in
development but just now on a slower
path and then in August some scoopers
claimed that the Nova show was scrapped
but that the studio would go back to
Nova further down the line they didn't R
out the possibility of like a Nova movie
though if you're looking for an easy way
to pamper yourself revamping your daily
hygiene routine is a great place to
start and geology is here to help
geology is a 29 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health opr daily hype Beast birdie
Esquire and GQ geology products use just
a handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by dermatologists
for decades geology can help you fight
acne reduce oiless prevent wrinkles
combat dark or puffy under eyes have
smoother or hydrated skin and Target
signs of aging you don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
code new rockstars 100 geology will give
you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body product when you
add it to your trial so 100% off plus an
additional 30% off hope you save some
champagne because this is a deal we're
celebrating click the link in the
description or go to G log. i/ rockstars
100 to get started we've actually
learned a lot more about xandar and its
history in the what if series the season
1 episode what if tala became Star-Lord
in the season 2 premiere what if nebula
joined the Nova cor now yes these
animated episodes represent hypothetical
elor scenarios set in alternate
universes but the facets of these
Baseline realities that are not
conditional to the Lynch pin incident
that gets flipped for each episode I
believe we can accept as normal MCU
canon in the liveaction part of the
universe that we've been following so
for example in what if season 2 episode
2 What If Peter Quill attacked Earth's
Mightiest Heroes that episode
establishes that King tacha's father
supplied Howard Stark with the vibranium
to make the original Captain American
prototype shield in the 1940s that bit
of History had nothing to do with
yondu's decision in 1988 to bring Peter
Quill directly to Ego therefore I think
we can accept it as true in the
liveaction MCU that daka's father and
Howard Stark knew each other and had
this deal same deal with Hela season 2
episode 7 what if Hela found the 10
rings establishes that fro was not
hela's mother Hela refers to frga as her
father's new girlfriend now since that
would be thousands of years in the past
and not conditional upon hela's Defiance
to Odin and Odin's decision to banish
her with IM Merc in his charm that
kickstarted that episode I think we can
conclude that in the live action MCU
frga Renee Russo is not the mother of
Hela Kate Blanchet this is how I see the
xandar episodes of the series as well
specifically there is a xandarian
Mainframe core and there is a xandarian
world mind similar to the cre Supreme
intelligence that we saw on Hala in the
Marvels and xandar does have a planetary
Shield that could keep out invading
conquerors with enough notice and if it
could keep out Ronin who did have the
power Stone it could probably also keep
about Thanos without the Power Stone
it's possible that Thanos could have
struck fast so that xandar didn't see
him coming like a smash and grab job but
that's not really thanos's style if you
look at every other society that he
conquered he has this massive Army he
loves to slowly loom in on everyone send
out ebony ma to do a whole speech like
he slowly appeared in front of the
Statesman in that Thor Ragnarok post
credit scene the Q ships all came down
on Earth and kind of this slow
Independence Day type formation like hey
look at us we're going to take our time
to get you so that would mean that
thanos's destruction of the planet of
xandar might have been aided by an
accomplice on the inside someone working
within Xander's power structure who
wanted him to do this someone in the
Nova cor must have struck a deal with
Thanos or wanted Thanos to obtain the
Power Stone why would any of them want
that though I don't think that someone
would have been Nova prime or Annie ryel
as it was her decision to keep the Power
Stone there and I don't think it was
Roman day I think it was the xandarian
world mind the xandarian world mind and
its infinite algorithm enhanced with
wisdom fed by all historical members of
xandarian society decided that the
suicidal sacrifice of xandar was the
best course of action because it for
saww a future cataclysmic event and saw
Thanos as all of higher life form's best
hope at avoiding what that threat was
that threat galatis and incursions that
Galactus is pissed off about Galactus as
the devour of Worlds sees it as His
function to be a planetary custodian he
consumes the energy of Worlds that are
past their primes which is his way of
kind of like gardening and shepherding
the cosmos to vent like the awful things
that planets sometimes do to unnaturally
prolong their lifespans things like what
we saw Hala resort to after Carol daners
annihilated their Supreme intelligence
using Quantum bands to tear holes in the
fabric of reality that's not good for
anyone so I believe the xandarian
worldmind could have computed the
Galactus was coming and this world mind
allowed Thanos to break into xandar it
told him where the Power Stone was and
allowed him to ravage this planet that
killed half of the population presumably
but it was a necessary sacrifice because
this would equip Thanos with the first
step of a population culling plan to
restore a balance across the cosmos and
to keep galatis from devouring
everything because think about it the
moment the blip ended that sudden flood
of Earth's population is what triggered
the emergence of the celestial teamat I
think these higher powers and the higher
World mins of the MCU wanted Thanos a
snap to happen and they saw Thanos as
like their hero their Champion their
best protection against things like
Galactus imagine this as a secret truth
carried on by Nova Richard Ryder or by
Silver Surfer and I still just love that
idea that Glen Close could explain this
to us one day as the voice of the mcu's
world mind so where would thanos's
return take place in upcoming MCU titles
if we can take Josh Brolin at his word
again a her filled cameo in adventure
Secret Wars is an easy answer Josh
broling returning as cable for Deadpool
3 in referencing his Thanos form I think
we could all see that too but to
establish thanos's real mission of
trying to saave off galatis and the
xandarian worldmind aiding him in that
Quest this kind of sounds like something
we could see as a prologue sequence of a
fantastic for hor film like think about
it looking ahead other than the Avengers
films Fantastic 4 seems like the only
Marvel title that's big and important
enough to justify Josh broland to return
as Thanos as the previous era's big bad
redefined as a noble Hero trying to stop
an even worse Cosmic threat but hey
would you rather see Thanos next in an
eternal sequel like having debates with
his brother Harry Styles Arrow Star Fox
would that even be an eternal sequel at
that point like would Marvel Studios
even benefit by slapping the eternals
name to top bill over characters that
the Marvel fan base finds more
interesting than eternals I want to hear
your thoughts in the comments below
where do you want to see Thanos next
subscribe to this new Rockstar channel
for breakdowns of everything you love
support us by grabbing one of these
Deadpool inspired Multiverse tour shirts
at nerd r. shop I'm Eric Voss thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye